that women generally want men with
sexual experience
i think it depends on the person to be
honest um i think personally yeah i
prefer someone with sexual experience
probably but i also would be with
someone without sexual experience if we
connected it just kind of depends on
your vibe is you know do you think that
women want a man with sexual experience
or no sexual experience yeah yeah
well i mean it's not like a trick
question it's yeah it's just yeah it's
an honest question yeah but i do think
it's possible to also be with someone
who doesn't have sexual experience just
because that's my preferred because
that's what i'm saying i mean a lot of
things
are possible you're going going like
like where does this even come up in the
like do you go oh hey i'm i've met this
girl i'm gonna maybe sleep with them or
how much exp like oh they're gonna go
how many how many girls have you slept
with oh what's the transaction like no i
think it's conversation with everyone i
sleep with like i actually ask every
single almost every single girl i meet
and hang out i'm just out of curiosity
do you put a lot of weight on that so if
a woman has left with a lot of like men
do you say okay i'm not gonna sleep with
you just because no i personally i i
love women who in general uh and i
definitely like hoes but i won't date
them why because uh i don't want a woman
i'm gonna be emotionally committed to to
have all this emotional baggage from a
past relationship so it doesn't
necessarily have this is kind of what i
was trying to say before it doesn't have
to equate to emotional baggage if if a
person chooses to acknowledge it and
take accountability for the fact that
they sucked a lot of people right you
can step out people can change their
habits would you say in general it does
in in i think general like
like a girl a girl like we had we had
linda on the show yeah yeah
this girl is so cute in innocent she she
she's 20 and a virgin yeah like she's
the cutest sweetie she was on the last
show what's her instagram
and and like like you could tell she had
no baggage no trauma like every like
like joke anyone would say like it would
just go over her head because she was so
innocent you just don't get that with
girls that have slept around a lot like
you can you can even if you don't know
their body count
like you can kind of just tell
because they're more damaged people can
have damage without having slept around
whatever you can have emotional baggage
without anything you can people
you're right you're correct you can't
but i'm saying in general yeah would you
say that the virgins tend to have less
baggage than the people that did only
fans say they probably have other
baggage
well what would that's what i mean maybe
less sexual background i like your
reactions but you need to learn to
articulate them like this is because i
love it i love that this blows my
[ __ ] mind
because this is all like i would not
even consider any one of these things a
prerequisite or a parameter for like
someone that i would potentially enter
into a relationship or have intimacy
with or like it just it would it's
completely [ __ ] foreign to me excuse
my language no no it's funny like like
it just
it's just completely foreign to me i
would not i like i don't understand it
i've been in polyamorous relationships
i've been like i like i've i i just i
just like yeah well just i just don't
understand it i just i i would never
even be like oh hey
hey we're like hanging out for the first
time how many people have you slept with
like i just wouldn't even wouldn't even
come into my brain how often are you
meeting new dating partners
like
fairly frequently so you're not
communicating with them what's that
you're not like communicating with them
but why not yeah yeah of course i am but
i i think the point is more that like
body count isn't really a part of when
you say people are interested
are you saying that you're in a
relationship
where the woman that you're with can
sleep with other men yeah i've been in
open relationships plenty like that was
actually my question i was one of those
yeah just want to clarify yeah yeah yeah
i'll gladly clarify so the woman that
you're with is actually cool with
sleeping with other men well like you're
cool with it well like it's like it's
not particularly in this
no not in this moment but you've been in
it yeah yeah many times many times but
it's also meant that i've been out of
sleep with other people so do you know
what a cockhold is i know exactly
exactly yeah that that's what that would
be yeah so you've been a cuckold no
no it's not it's not great because it's
completely consensual it's completely
with boundaries in place do you have any
preference is that a curiosity in terms
of what uh whether you guys have an open
relationship or just committed
relationship
um i normally prefer an open
relationship
so you prefer her being able to sleep
with other guys and me to go to sleep
with other people
no judgement on it i'm just curious like
you it doesn't matter to you she comes
home she got railed by three different
dudes and then she comes back says baby
i love you i'm just like
and i think i think as well with that it
kind of allows for sorry yes my my
masculine views and that fragile i'm
quite i'm like i don't i don't know how
much masculinity you have after a woman
is you're allowing your woman to get
penises from somewhere else sweet how do
you define masculinity
um
men are territorial creatures are they
yeah they are okay and um
if my woman yes your woman
stated that this is mine is gonna tell
me that she's gonna go and get a penis
from somewhere else and she can just go
there yes you know i mean you're not
going to come back but you can go and
i'm saying maybe maybe
i would say that the majority of men i
think that i would be
okay in saying the majority of men would
not want their woman being [ __ ] down
by somebody else maybe that's a case of
your own masculinity being a little bit
fragile then if you're not it's biology
we said no it's not biology you keep
using that term i just think men don't
like wife in these hoes
come on it's okay to sleep with them
just don't date them
i said why like but like but like
it's like okay because you are your
habit so i wouldn't want to date a guy
that's cheated on every single
girlfriend that he's ever had and and so
i can understand why i wouldn't want to
date a girl that's been sleeping around
for 10 years because it's gonna be hard
to to one day stop and i honestly feel
the same way a little bit about guys
because if a dude's been sleeping around
forever what are the odds i'm gonna get
him to settle down right and so like i
can understand where guys are coming
from you just guys put some really
[ __ ] weird parameters i'm just saying
the woman that you're letting go out and
sleep with other men she's not yours
she's not your woman of course she's not
mine i don't own anything so she's not
streaming
no no she's she's her own autonomous
individual person
like she's not my possession
you seem to be putting a lot of
ownership onto your onto your girlfriend
you seem to be acting like you should
have a a a a collar around her neck and
she's your pet i mean i like that yeah
yeah
i'm not even i'm not here for [ __ ]
king shame and either don't get me don't
get me wrong
don't get me wrong but you're putting a
lot of you're putting a lot of oh she is
mine whereas i'm saying no this person
that i'm with is their own alternative
if i was to get married to a guy i would
feel like i'm hers we'll see
genuinely like yeah i don't intend on
ever getting married i think i think
it's i think i think the idea of
marriage is quite strange to be honest
so like and i and i get that it's not
for everyone but i i like i don't really
mind the idea of like belonging to a guy
i actually kind of like it of course
yeah of course and that's your own
priority isn't it but like
but
do you want a guy specifically saying
that they control you and that you're
it's not yeah i mean i think i think
there are levels but i would like i
would like a guy that could lead me and
make decisions for us and i would really
like a guy that i could trust to make
decisions you're concerned as well
though with with your consent on top of
that well yeah it's submission not yeah
not to just force there well i don't i
think all of i think all of the guys are
like they want a guy that a girl not a
guy
a girl that wants to follow them
it's not like they want to they want a
girl that doesn't want to be there
so so like i'm saying like if if i was
with a guy and he wanted to have an open
relationship on both ends i would i
would be concerned i would think like
what
because i would i would trust your
judgment because as many of you know i
was just banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible